el presidente sebastián piñera convocó
este domingo a la sesión inaugural de la
convención constituyente en la que los
155 personas elegidas por la ciudadanía
en los comicios del pasado 15 y 16 de
mayo serán oficialmente ratificadas la
sesión tendrá lugar el próximo domingo 4
de julio a las 10 de la mañana y en ella
tendrán que elegir al que será su
presidente o presidenta y también al
vicepresidente o vicepresidenta
recordemos que esta convención
constituyente está formada por 78
hombres y 77 mujeres en la que será la
primera convención constituyente
paritaria de toda la historia y en la
que también están 17 personas que
representan a los 10 pueblos originarios
que existen en chile la convención
constituyente deberá definir de forma
autónoma el reglamento por el que va a
funcionar y en el que se establecerán
cuestiones como la forma en que se van
vincular o no con la ciudadanía a partir
de este 4 de julio la convención
constituyente tendrá un plazo de 9 meses
prorrogable durante tres meses más en
total un año para elaborar una nueva
carta magna destinada a reemplazar a la
que chile heredó de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet en 1980 a partir de que
la constitución sea
por los constituyentes habrá un plazo de
60 días para convocar un nuevo sufragio
de salida en el que los chilenos
decidirán si aceptan o no esta nueva
constitución